I can't believe you're going to be
voicing bumblebee yes in Transformers
one I've heard that Chris and Scarlet
have said to me that the footage looks
really cool oh cool I'm curious what
it's like voicing a Bumblebee and I
watched the trailer it's not out yet for
Kung Fu Panda 4 this morning and noticed
that you're again a voice in an upcoming
uh am I wrong about this cuz I'm like oh
no no you're oh yeah know you look I'm
like oh maybe I'm wrong about this but
yeah I saw you another big you know
animated thing what can you tease about
your role in that it just that it was
incredibly fun to to work obviously
again with with Jack who I think is is
incredible uh an incredible performer um
that's so good on oh thank you yeah
thank you yeah that's great I didn't
know that you were doing that that's
awesome that is really awesome um like I
said it's almost like you guys are
dominating every upcoming animated
project animated project we're we're
thinking of our own we're trying to work
on what are we what are we going to do
on our own thing yeah we're our own
little didly where it's a prequel to
migration so CHP chump and deloy
specifically chump and deloy yeah yeah
we think we might do that and then we'll
do other voices in that movie we we
should do other voices in that movie
voice in the only the enti in the entire
movie and we um oh Transformers yeah the
the the trans um playing bumblebee I
it's funny not a lot of affectation to
my voice the director of of this wanted
really just wanted he goes I really want
your voice I just want Keegan's voice so
it's kind of Keegan as Bumblebee and you
you you'll see it's interesting it's not
it's unlike this where I'm working in a
dialect or I'm doing something with like
Super Mario Brothers where I'm really
trying to disguise my voice this one's
I'm I'm bringing a lot of me to
it